we're herd animals so fear is contagious
that's how we've survived as a species
if somebody starts running we all just
start running with them but if you have
an entire banking industry an entire
media industry an entire all everybody
telling you run run all the time I went
out the back door there was five deer
standing there and uh one of them got
spooked and the other four are going
we're running but why are we running why
are we running we don't know why we're
running let's see other guys running so
we're running yes that's exactly what
that's what we're doing it's cracking up
we like to think we're sophisticated
Dave our brains are operating at that
level when we are scared we're running
but I don't know why I don't know why
we're running